[Music]
Tucker Carlson had [ __ ] Kanye West on
yesterday which that was weird he sure
did huh yeah
yeah so there's a lot of stuff that came
out of the interview I have one of my
favorite Clips here but I also want to
play the Clinton one because I think
it's worth listening to also gotta say
Kanye didn't sound crazy in this
interview I'll tell you that right now
he sounded very reasoned he sounded very
not like a not like the crazy person
they kept painting him as to be not that
he wasn't actually crazy he was using
his put up on white guy accent though
good point like he was doing his fake
white guy thing well not really his
mother was like the [ __ ] head of the
English Department at the University of
Chicago so it's not I don't think they
spoke a bonix in his house is my point
no I get that but like you know 20 years
of being like yo Nicholson Paris y'all
like you know like the like he knows how
to turn it on he knows how to turn it on
and off is my point good time what
you're saying is he was trying to get
the job yeah he's got that eye talking
to my teacher voice okay well uh let's
see the first indication that West might
become a massive problem for the
industrial deception complex came in
2015 and 2016 When Donald Trump appeared
and West had a very strong gut reaction
to Trump that was very positive and the
people around him were panicked by this
the last thing you could have is one of
the most popular pop culture figures in
America coming out for Donald Trump so
they applied intense pressure to get him
back on the script and apparently his
wife was part of that his former wife
Kim Kardashian can I say that's the
other thing about this interview that I
saw that I thought was hilarious there
was a lot more [ __ ] on Kim
Kardashian than I was expecting but
there was entire segments of like she
called me crazy because I bought this
the house next door to hers because I
wanted to see her kids and I don't want
to give an excuse so I couldn't see the
kids and I'm like okay that actually
makes sense if you could do it why
wouldn't you you know and who West now
learns had a very close relationship
with the clintons and people around the
clintons he had no idea his relationship
with Trump on the other hand flourished
and he got a window into into the people
around Trump and in this clip you'll
hear him assess what happened inside the
White House very interesting watch
it was interesting a friend of mine told
me that
uh Chris and Kim had called him because
he had influence inside of the black
community
uh
and had called him
uh
to say oh to get him to influence people
to take the vaccination and
I don't have opinion on that I just want
to say that as a flat statement did you
see that that long pause was that forced
people to take the vaccine you saw him
do a
I don't have an opinion on that stop on
that one by the way when you took that
long to say that I have a feeling you do
have an opinion on that one don't you
but it was
it was wild that I didn't know how close
my own wife was to the clintons
I didn't know you know
I I didn't realize it at the time that
you were married to her and well I was
married to her
how close was she to the clintons
I mean cell phone away like
and that's what it is
it's all these power Brokers which
you're about to find out in a clip I'm
going to play here in a second when it
wasn't people think it's just the Latin
no no no no once you hear about the
Kushner stuff that's even better or hey
tell yay to say this away or hey go out
and use your platform to push uh the
vaccination away I mean not a way but
like take the away part but do you feel
like at times you were manipulated by
political forces through your wife
attempt manipulation but yes there was
some manipulation me not saying I like
trump it was a form of a manipulation
for sure yeah why did you like him by
the way you said you liked him early
like you saw him I mean
uh I I keep telling this joke if people
say Trump was the first black president
I'm gonna be the first Latino president
because all the values the the
conservative values just line up come on
man Trump says what do you mean he has
his own buildings
he's the only say what you want about
him he is the only rapper after Trump
got elected it was like we used to rap
about this guy we used to wanted to be
this guy every song was like Trump tight
yeah [ __ ] rolling like Trump yeah yeah
Trump Tower and that's a real that why
wouldn't you like somebody that did that
you know
what are you talking about he's like
like Ralph Lauren yeah he made Ivanka
you like Ivanka yes here it is here it
is you tweet you wrote a post on
Instagram about her husband today
Jared Kushner oh oh oh oh oh you're
getting too close Kanye Flying Too Close
to the sun my man is he is he is he have
those waxy Wings on you think is that a
[ __ ] chill bro you know he was like
[ __ ] He's one more interview away
from naming them do it I had a dinner
with
Ivanka Jared and Josh you think when he
brings to the Kushner isn't real Israel
thing you think Ice Cube Ice Cube is
doing like this to the screen like the
Leo Leo meme like that's what I've been
saying no one listen to me
and a couple days later I found out that
Josh Kushner had ten percent Jared's
brother
of scams which really weird right
why would Jared kushner's brother own 10
percent
of one of Kurt Kim and his companies
right to the line that I had developed
with Kim
and I had a lot of issues with the
imagery of of skims I felt like there
was a lot of imagery that was overly
sexualized and things that I wouldn't
want to see my wife and definitely not
my daughter's doing in the future in
order to sell product
based
nothing he's saying whatever you think
of his intentions just judging the words
was what I'm doing yeah what's wrong
with that he's right uh
but it reaches another level when it's
like okay well this is what my wife is
doing and this is what they're doing for
this is what she's doing for our
children
but it reaches another level when her
business partners are
Jewish
telling piece of company that they don't
have to because the company's already so
successful and it's a internet-based
company so it's like they're really just
selling off the company in order to
create more relationships for themselves
so what you're saying is that they were
using you and Kim Kardashian to help
connect you to more powerful people to
then push the policies that they wanted
yeah crazy right Kanye
that are unneeded it's like when I went
to the Gap and with our release they
just like
uh they shoveled it out I'm very
cautious of with my words I'm really big
on being able to have an adult
conversation in front of the children so
I I don't use a Jewish guy using a black
fella to push a social agenda what
whatever I don't know but somebody told
him to say [ __ ] the police explicit
language uh in interviews especially so
I found out after this dinner that Josh
Kushner had 10 percent of skims and I
had five percent of scams
and regardless
so he had more
of Kim's company than [ __ ] enough
co-founder oh if you know Josh Kushner
figured out how to put 150 million
dollars I'm sure it wasn't out of his
own account but 150 million and I'm sure
Jarrett still has a piece of that fun
uh
the uh regardless of them putting that
money in for me to have been a owner in
it and not known just from a place as a
creative where skims is so based on a
lot of the easy ideas then it's based on
all of the relationships
in fashion because I had to use my
relationships in fashion in order to
establish Kim in a way where
fashionable people say hey I'm I'm down
to where Kim's line
and these VCS they come in and they get
a piece of it after the fact and they
run around and say they have ownership
in it so as I put on my Instagram which
you know luckily for everyone they could
just write it off that you know I'm
crazy until they see my disposition in
this interview and then it's going to
get scary uh
they um
Too Close buddy Easy by the way I agree
with what you're saying but you be
careful I'm just telling you but I don't
want you you know I'm just saying
um
hey Josh what if uh what if I had 10 of
Carly Claus's lingerie shapewear
swimsuit line
and you have five percent of it
and you didn't know
how would that make you feel
and then after talking to them
and really sitting with Jared and
sitting with Josh
and finding out other pieces of
information I was like wow these guys
might have really been holding Trump
back
you think gee
if only there were other people saying
that yep only like everyone that helped
get them elected were saying that yeah
right yeah and then they at least you
got rid of Bannon though yeah the one
the only guy I liked
to Handler right then they'd love to
just look at me or look at Trump like
we're so crazy and that they're the
businessman so when I think about all of
these things that Jared's you know
somehow doesn't get enough credit for
with his work and what is it is working
Israel or his work and how what what is
this what was it Palestine he almost
said people stop he's almost to
Palestine Israel or Pat pal you know
where he made these peace treaties in
Israel where was that do you know the
facts on this right here so I'm like
well I think that was between Israel and
some of the Arab Nations
I just think it was to make money
oh
that's a spicy meat to ball as they
would say
Mamma Mia
I don't know is that is that too
heavy-handed to put on this platform no
that's that's your opinion we're not in
a censorship business okay thank you and
I just think that that's what they're
about
is making money I don't think that they
have the ability to make anything
on their own I think they were born into
money I think we bombed that pipeline
like I'm just saying dog like there's a
lot of [ __ ]
but when he says they're who's he
talking about listen to this I just
think it was used to make money yeah
I don't know is that is that too
heavy-handed to put on this platform no
that's that's your opinion we're not in
a censorship business okay thank you and
I just think that that's what they're
about
is making money I don't think that they
have the ability to make anything
on their own I think they were born into
money
and for me is a Maverick and a talent
and a person that's been
you know beat kicked lost everything
said to have lost my mind
went from pool myself up by my boot my
boots don't have straps on it but I say
pull myself up for my boots yeah Yeezys
don't have laces
to becoming a multi-billionaire that
gets
uh that gets the you know um the the
price every year of my my network goes
down every year uh on Forbes they just
keep on going slowly just taking it down
every year it's like really a weird
thing but as a person that has really
built something from nothing
when I sit across
the table from a Josh Kushner and he
just feels so entitled to that idea and
this person has never brought anything
of value
other than so-called being a good
venture capitalist I have a major I have
a major issue with that and it makes me
feel like they weren't serving my boy
Trump
the way we could have because
he's the biggest guy with a platform I
will say that I said that publicly
right because everybody talked about the
Kushner thing and Kushner was no good
for nobody mainstream said it nobody did
this step talk yeah right right right of
course I'm just saying like
it's it's like yeah I like how he goes
yeah you know they really [ __ ] over my
boy Trump
that's the last thing he posted to his
Instagram today
oh yeah I just saw that
[Laughter]
oh
he said and I quote I'm gonna make it so
[ __ ] won't feel like talking to me no
more
but regardless of what you say about
Kanye this is the thing that I do like
anything that makes them feel
uncomfortable or squirm is okay by me
that's anything that makes them go like
shut the [ __ ] up shut this [ __ ] guy
up
Shadow mode makes me happy
hold on I'm sorry I'm so sorry to go
back
go to Show links and look at this post
it won't even notice how it won't pop oh
wow what even Auto pop it won't even
Auto populate yeah what is that what did
he say
okay who is this puffy yeah Puff Daddy
okay so it looks like the top one is
what Puff Daddy sent him
this is what I thought he was gonna show
first Puff Daddy tweeted
[ __ ] send me an address let's stop
playing these internet games and don't
feel threatened you'll be fine just love
he replies this ain't a game I'm gonna
use you as an example to show the Jewish
people that told you to call me that no
to tell me that told you to call me that
no one can threaten me or influence me I
told you this was war now
gone get you some business oh easy of
the fourth right holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
this is real yeah I'm looking at it this
is his
what the [ __ ] oh
[Music]
this ain't a game imma use you an exam
as an example to show the Jewish people
that told you to call me that no one can
threaten or influence me I told you this
was war now go and get you some business
so wait a second all of this because he
went on Tucker Carlson
and that is true it seems to me in this
text message that puffy doesn't text him
on the reg as they say you know what I
mean Puffy's not normally texting him so
somebody told him you need to call him
and you need to call him now because
unless you want another dead rapper on
you you know what happened with puffy
they probably said look we let that
other guy take the fall for that
shooting you clearly did okay yeah so
here's the other shooting that you
probably did
so here's what you're going to do you're
going to do whatever the [ __ ] we say now
do you hear me and he's like nah man you
already made me go out with Jennifer
Lopez for so long I thought we were even
he's like nope we're just getting
started
uh why do you think Sean John exists
those jeans suck
[ __ ] Wild
go off King hell yeah